it's time for another challenge charlie
hello I'm gonna do something a bit
stupid today I've been challenged by the
good people of Twitter to dye my head
bright red sometimes teenagers have this
thing where they decide that they want
to rebel against the world and the best
way that they can come up with to do
this rebelling is to dye their hair
personally I'm not really rebellious at
all but I am still a teenager and while
I am still a teenager I feel like I can
get away with having a red head so let's
go for it okay the first thing on my
list is to have a little bit of a change
of clothing tada Here I am wearing a
towel and some very noisy gloves next I
have to remove the applicator nozzle
from the developer bottle pierce the
live color Chrome true but the reverse
of the cap and carefully squeeze the
content into the developer bottle so
basically I have to pour this into this
can really see me right now but I don't
really want to have a load of hair dye
on my floor so I'm doing this over a
table and this is the shaking part as
you can see it's turning a little bit
flesh colored which is not the color I
want but I'm sure it'll be fine and
after I finish taking this I have to
straight away start applying it to my
head I've never done this to myself
before so I'm slightly worried about
this bit I get up a do it wrong it'll
make a fun video Hey okay let's go as
you can see behind me we have the timer
activated we're a very odd species
aren't we this really isn't something
that you see anywhere else in nature
here or now I'm really worried about how
much of it is actually on my forehead my
towel is falling off Mattel is falling
off is it just me or does that look
orange to you this stuff is really
starting to smell really funny do you
know who I remind myself most of at the
moment knuckles from Sonic the Hedgehog
before I did this I was so adamant about
the fact that I would not get any on my
forehead as well and I've just failed
completely this is a never-ending bottle
of henna dye it's just going on forever
and ever I swear it is there it is see
oh my friend Tom recently dyed his hair
bright blue I told my friend Alex that I
was doing this as well and I said you
should bleach your hair and then me Alex
and Tom could form a band and we could
be called the primary colors and it
would be really really lame so a good
thing we're not doing that a
we're almost out of hair dye I think I
might have completely ruined this towel
don't tell anyone
so it says that once I've done this all
I have to do is rinse it which
definitely is something I would have
instinctively wanted to do three minutes
left
two minutes left my head one minute left
five four three two one hi it looks a
bit dark at the moment because it's
still a bit wet but it is red so just
looks at myself in the mirror and I my
hair is still red it's actually happened
I have just dyed my hair red that is
what I just did I mean there's nothing I
can save really without just kind of
pointing out the obvious it's red oh my
god - my hair is red I guess it's gonna
be easier for people to find me out on
the street no because I've got this kind
of big siren the head yeah I like it
okay I'm gonna put some trousers on so
that's all we have time for here on
charlie is so cool like red have you got
anything to say before we leave new hat
hello I'm Charlie's red hair that's
great
bye you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
have you got anything to say before we
leave mister hand